on a vu plein de choses très drôle passé
sur les réseaux pour les mecs thèmes
envisagés une saint valentin dans un
célèbre fast-food
sachez qu'ils ont posté un message pour
vous regardez regardez
burger king camille message à ceux qui
commandent burger king avec leur moitié
pour la saint valentin
même nous on conscience il une
déclaration d'amour faite par patrick
balkany à sa femme dans les rues de
levallois ville dont il est maire
regardez alors ça je crois que c'est un
fait qui en fait c'est vrai c'est
énormissime regarder ce qu'il a fait
regardez fleurs un viser une pensée
aussi tous les moyens étaient bons pour
célébrer l'amour et puis il ya patrick
balkany
l'ancien maire de la commune des
hauts-de-seine a fait afficher sur ce
panneau d'information municipale une
déclaration d'amour que je vous cite
forcément à toi isabelle joyeuse saint
valentin je t'aime pratique c'est très
mignon un message remarquer partagé par
la principale intéressée sur les réseaux
sociaux vos efforts seront axés dar k je
suis désolé juste la taille marquée que
ce que vous avez fait avec jean pierre
pernaut à la saint valentin mais je suis
préparé un petit déjeuner way et ensuite
en tant que juif déposé sur son lit
ouais et après j'ai remis la physique du
sper annuaire fait seule la géographie
de stars à lui oui j'aimerais gf est
resté le strip tease de stars hadden oui
moi devant jean pierre pernaut oui
devant marie j'avais voulu refaire la
petite surprise
non et là il ya dix jours en profiter
mais les parrainer quoi il va les gêner
ah bah oui c'est normal
bravo al aqsa c'est l'amour
[Applaudissements]